ein ort irgendwo in deutschland hier
treffe ich eine junge frau anfang 30 sie
möchte unerkannt bleiben
ich nenne sie sarah sie steht mitten im
leben doch nach einem schweren
allergischen schock und einem autounfall
ist plötzlich nichts mehr so wie es
vorher war
es ist zb ich sitze im auto und fahre
meines weges und mit einmal denke ich
ist irgend etwas komisch und dann häufig
in mich rein dann fängt mein herz
anzuschlagen meine hände fangen an zu
schwitzen
mir wird schwindlig und dann steigt die
panik wortwörtlich in einem hoch mehr
war in der woche hat sarah
angstzuständen beim autofahren im zug
und in ihren träumen geschäftsreisen
werden zum problem
krankschreibungen häufen sich also als
ganz normale gesunde junge frau die
eigentlich mitten im leben steht hat
mich das vollkommen aus der bahn
geworfen
ich hatte ja es war wirklich wie eine
art kontrollverlust
ich wusste nicht wann es kommt ich
wusste nicht in welcher intensität es
kommt und ich war wirklich einfach
überfordert und müde
sarah beschließt sich hilfe zu suchen
ihre hausärztin regiert zu einem
psychotherapie
damit habe ich lange gehadert denn für
mich ist das immer das hatten immer nur
die anderen
sie bekommt erste gesprächstermine bei
einem therapeuten der gesetzlich
versicherte behandelt der hat mir dann
am ende dieser vier sitzungen ein
formular ausgestellt dass ich eine
therapie dringend brauchen aber dass er
keine plätze mehr in seiner therapie
praxis frei hat die langeweile die
wartezeit die wartezeit in seiner praxis
war weit über ein halbes jahr
diagnose angststörung sarah telefoniert
therapeuten ab doch sie bekommt nur
absagen und das obwohl psychotherapie
eine leistung der gesetzlichen
krankenkasse ist niemand konnte mir
einen platz anbieten in naher zukunft
die gangster antwort war ich kann sie
auf meine warteliste schreiben und die
zweithäufigste antwort war tatsächlich
ich habe so viele anfragen bekommen
musste meine warteliste schließen und
deshalb kann ich sie leider nicht mehr
aufnehmen
es war unglaublich frustrierend und ich
habe die ganze zeit nur gedacht so wird
es erst einmal nichts dass ich mein
leben wieder normalisiert rund 30
psychotherapeuten hat sarah
abtelefoniert wie sie sagt schließlich
wendet sie sich an eine privatpraxis
rund 3000 euro hat sarah für die
therapiesitzungen aus eigener tasche
bezahlen der cc
gesetzlich versicherte warten im schnitt
fünf monate auf einen therapieplatz für
menschen in einer krise eine zumutung
in der nähe von bottrop bin ich mit der
psychotherapeutin dr johanna tinker
verabredet sie gründete vor fünf jahren
eine gemeinschaftspraxis und engagiert
sich in ihren berufsverband für eine
bessere versorgung
sie und ihre kolleginnen können
gesetzlich versicherte behandeln der
andere ist groß die warteliste ist
einfach noch liste mit daten und wenn
wir hier oben schauen sehen wir wirklich
die ersten beiden einträge die sind vom
elften april 2009 10 wobei die oberste
patienten mit der vereinbarten termin
für das erstgespräch das in deutschland
kontakt aber der rest war gleich darauf
dass therapie kapazitäten frei werden
und wie viele leute stehen aktuell auf
dieser liste band heute morgen 200
völlig was macht das mit ihnen wenn sie
diese liste sehen
und ganz ehrlich ich finde es
schrecklich also leuten am telefon oder
auch im gespräch sagen okay wir haben
probleme ich bin psychotherapeut und ich
könnte ihnen helfen aber ich kann nicht
weil ich keine zeit habe
das fürchterlich für beide seiten jede
woche gibt es fünf bis zehn neue
anfragen und häufig ist die not groß wie
diese mail zeigt die korona pandemie
verschärft die situation
da sind jetzt eben zu deren alltags
herausforderung doch die pandemische
herausforderung dazugekommen geldsorgen
kinderbetreuung und den arbeitsplatz
angst vor infektionen so dass sich auch
vermehrt menschen melden die jetzt eben
in einer seelische krise geraten sind
und durchaus auch mal nicht dass die
psychische störung oder auch
abhängigkeitserkrankungen entwickelt
haben anfang 2000 21 sind die anfragen
in den praxen um 40 prozent im vergleich
zum vorjahreszeitraum gestiegen ergab
eine umfrage der deutschen
psychotherapeutenvereinigung unter ihren
mitgliedern
die langen wartezeiten sind seit jahren
ein problem bereits 2017 gab es eine
reform der psychotherapie richtlinie und
weitere änderungen
seitdem gibt es für patienten an den
anspruch auf sprechstunden zur abklärung
und behandlung für dringende fälle
zudem ist ein termin servicestellen
diese termine vermitteln betroffene
bekommen jetzt zwar schneller eine
einschätzung ob eine behandlung nötig
ist doch an fehlenden therapieplätzen
habe die reform laut johanna thünker
nichts geändert
[Musik]
für viele psychotherapeuten ist die hohe
nachfrage eine benutzung nicht hätte den
präsidenten der
bundespsychotherapeutenkammer dr
dietrich uns
was sind die reform von 2017 den
psychotherapeuten gebracht für die
kolleginnen und kollegen erhöht das den
druck jetzt habe ich jemanden der eine
behandlung braucht ich habe aber kein
behandlungsplatz und müssen dann
versuchen entweder bei kolleginnen
kollegen nachzusuchen
damit die patienten eine behandlung
finden oder den patienten dann sagen tut
mir leid aber wir die behandlung kann
ich frühestens in fünf sechs sieben
monaten wenn da wir ein behandlungsplatz
frei wird beginnen
wir wissen auch dass manche dann
resignieren gerade zum beispiel menschen
mit depression in den entsteht zunehmend
mehr das gefühl mir kann doch niemand
helfen und das ist das grundgefühl der
depression dass mir niemand helfen
können das wird jetzt durch dieses
system noch verstärkt grundsätzlich gebe
es genügend psychotherapeuten aber zu
wenige die einen so genannten kassen
sitz haben und damit gesetzlich
versicherte behandeln können
die anzahl und räumliche verteilung von
ärzten und psychotherapeuten wird durch
die sogenannte bedarfsplanung festgelegt
anhand dieser darstellung kann ihnen
zeigen dass hier 1999 als die
bedarfsplanung eingeführt wurde
insbesondere in den neuen bundesländern
zu wenig kiefer therapeuten da waren
eigentlich hätte man fordern müssen dass
die versorgung wie sie hier
durchschnittlich in den alten
bundesländern ist auch auf die neuen
bundesländer übertragen wird
realisiert wurde die bedarfsplanung dann
so dass dort mittelwert als neuer
standard festgelegt wurde dass der lange
von vor 20 jahren zieht sich bis heute
das problem ist 20 jahre alt war
psychische erkrankungen können jeden
treffen im schnitt erkranken jährlich
und 28 prozent der erwachsenen an einer
psychischen störung zu den häufigsten
erkrankungen zählen angststörungen
depressionen sowie erkrankungen durch
alkohol und medikamenten immer nur
menschen die eine psychotherapie
die zahl hat sich in den letzten neun
jahren verdoppelt
[Musik]
viele menschen sind immer wieder auf
hilfe angewiesen denn manchmal begleitet
sie die erkrankung ein leben lang
thomas schaaf ski kennt das system und
seine hürden seit vielen jahren der 55
jährige leidet an depressionen
dackel naki hat für ihn eine besondere
bedeutung und 20 freikarten vorher hatte
er hat gesagt er sagte mal ein und das
besser als jeder fahrer kann
und das stimmt auch golding morgens raus
kommt sie mal so als ob jemand einen den
strom abschaltet und dann dann kommen
sie nicht raus und der sitzt auf mich
letztlich sondern im gesicht ist mir das
gelingt der lucky schaltet den strom
angenommen wenn er könnte würde den
ganzen tag draußen bleiben
seit über 30 jahren lebt der
rentenberater mit seiner erkrankung
sie ist ein teil von ihm und seinem
alltag er nimmt medikamente und ist in
therapie
[Musik]
also ich hätte mir mein leben schon ein
bisschen anders vorgestellt aber das ist
nun mal so die krankheit ist da und
dieses anscheinend zu spät behandelt
worden und dadurch chronisch geworden
und von da kann ich muss ich damit leben
und ich habe mich entschlossen nicht
mein leben nützlich zu verbringen
wie hat sich die depression auf ihr
arbeitsleben ausgebildet also ich sag
mal so wenn ich bei einem in einem
normalen beschäftigungsverhältnis wer
das würde nicht gehen also doch relativ
schnell raus es gibt natürlich dadurch
auch erhebliche brüche bei mir im
lebenslauf
irgendwann bin ich dann in die
selbstständigkeit gegangen weil ich dann
einfacher mit meiner krankheit umgehen
kann und meine depressionen und wenn es
mal an einem tag nicht geht dann muss
ich ja auch nicht unbedingt etwas machen
und so hoffe ich dass mein berufsleben
um meine krankheit herum gebaut
für viele andere betroffene ist das
nicht möglich die folgen von psychischen
erkrankungen sind ihnen
sie verursachen 16 5 prozent aller
fehltage 2009/10 laden die
volkswirtschaftlichen kosten durch
produktionsausfall bei 14 4 milliarden
euro
41 7 prozent waren psychische
erkrankungen der hauptgrund für
erwerbsminderungsrente
auf seinen aktuellen therapieplatz hat
thomas scholz je ein halbes jahr
gewartet an den wartezeiten habe sich in
den letzten jahren
wenig verbessert da wird halt nur daran
herumgedoktert es gibt jetzt so eine
hotline die man anrufen kann wo man dann
einen ersten termin kriegt aber man
wartet trotzdem weiter auf die therapie
und man darf nicht vergessen die
personen eine schwere erkrankung die
auch tödlich sein kann
psychische erkrankungen bedeuten für
viele betroffene schweres leid und sie
haben gravierende auswirkungen auf
gesundheitssystem und wirtschaften
die politik hat das erkannt im herbst
2020 werden gleich drei ministerien mit
einer offensive für mehr offenheit im
umgang mit psychischen belastungen und
für bessere prävention
psychische erkrankungen haben in den
letzten jahren so stark zugenommen dass
wir inzwischen von erheblichen
volkswirtschaftlichen schaden sprechen
müssen und es geht darum dass wir eben
schaffen dieses thema über alle
gesellschaftlichen schichten hinweg über
alle altersgruppen hinweg deutlich zu
kommunizieren dass wir uns trauen
darüber zu sprechen dass es bessere
vernetzte strukturen gibt gerade für die
metro behandlungsbedarf dass man nicht
von pontius zu pilatus muss sondern
schnell entsprechende
behandlungsangebote auffindet
prävention ist das eine doch die politik
kann nur die rahmenbedingungen für die
versorgung der rund 73 millionen
gesetzlich versicherten setzen denn im
gesundheitswesen gilt das prinzip der
selbstverwaltung der sogenannte
gemeinsame bundesausschuss gba
entscheidet darüber welche leistungen
die gesetzlichen krankenkassen zahlen
das betrifft auch den bereich
psychotherapie der gba ist eine
machtvolle instanz er setzt sich unter
anderem aus vertretern der ärzte und
psychotherapeuten auf der einen sowie
vertretern der krankenkassen auf der
anderen seite zusammen
zudem gibt es unparteiische mitglieder
und patientenvertreter letztere haben
allerdings kein stimmrecht im
gemeinsamen bundesausschuss wird auch
ein rahmen für die anzahl und räumliche
verteilung von ärzten und
psychotherapeuten festgelegt die
vorgaben werden dann auf landesebene
umgesetzt 2009 10 wurde die richtlinie
angepasst
ein vom gba beauftragtes gutachten hat
damals für psychotherapeuten bis zu 2400
zusätzliche kassen sitze empfohlen
doch es wurden nur knapp 800 gerade mal
ein drittel wie kann das sein
antworten suche ich auf einem symposium
für eine gerechte psychotherapeutische
versorgung dass sich anfang des jahres
besucher wegen der pandemie findet es
digital statt
zu gast sind auch politiker
verschiedener parteien
ich frage nach wie finden sie das der
gemeinsame bundesausschuss nicht mehr
kassen sätze ermöglicht hat ich glaube
ist er sinnvoll wenn sich da noch einmal
damit beschäftigt ist das dann leider
eine leistung der selbstverwaltung wo
ich großer versetzung in die nicht
optimal was eigentlich an so dass wir
gesetzt haben dann nicht als grundlage
dem dabei rede ich nicht davon dass man
vielleicht um 20 nach oben ab gleich das
ist nicht der punkt aber in dieser
drastischen form daneben zu legen halte
ich ehrlich gesagt auch völlig verkehrt
ich bitte um ein interview beim
gemeinsamen bundesausschuss doch das sei
momentan nicht möglich schriftlich heißt
es zu den gutachten das zusätzlich
eigene modellrechnungen und weitere
erkenntnisse berücksichtigt worden seien
außerdem verweist der gba auf diverse
möglichkeiten vor ort von den vorgang
abweichen zu können und auf ein neu
eingeführtes berechnungsverfahren
damit wird die bedarfsplanung stärker an
der regionalen entwicklung der
bevölkerung orientiert
zudem weiß der gba darauf hin dass sich
durch die etablierung der
psychotherapeutischen sprechstunde 2017
die wartezeiten auf ein erstgespräch
stark verkürzt hätten und
die wartezeit auf eine richtlinien
therapie habe sich von 2011 23 vier
wochen auf 2017 19,9 wochen ebenfalls
die vier wochen verkürzt
sei aber immer noch zu lang inwieweit
ihre form von 2017 greift würde 2022
bewertet die
bundespsychotherapeutenkammer kann nicht
nachvollziehen warum sich der gemeinsame
bundesausschuss für weniger kassen sitze
als empfohlen entschieden hat wir haben
das auch sehr kritisiert von seiten der
psychotherapeutenkammer das hier dieses
gutachten nicht entsprechend angewandt
wurde und auch das
bundesgesundheitsministerium darauf
hingewiesen dass hier das was er
eigentlich wissenschaftlich begründet
war nicht umgesetzt wurde so im
gemeinsamen bundesausschuss sind das
sehr schwierige verhandlungen weil hier
sowohl die kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen die kassen der
bundesvereinigung die an die
krankenkassen das miteinander aushandeln
müssen und die krankenkassen große
befürchtungen haben dass die
aufwendungen für psychotherapie zu hoch
werden
da geht es viel ums geld und da bremsen
die krankenkassen schon sehr stark sind
es also die kassen die eine bessere
versorgung verhindern
im gemeinsamen bundesausschuss sitzt der
spitzenverband der krankenkassen
ich treffe dessen pressesprecher florian
lanz wie sieht er die versorgung und
weltweit maßstab sind ja sowieso ganz
weit vorne als systemen was die absolute
anzahl an psychotherapeuten anbelangt
aber auch die tatsache dass sie
selbstverständlich von den gesetzlichen
krankenkassen und damit von ihren und
von meinen beiträgen bezahlt werden und
die zahl vermehrt sich permanent das
heißt nicht dass alles perfekt wäre
wer letzte das behaupten würde aber zu
sagen wir haben in deutschland eine
dramatische situation es sei alles
schlecht ist ganz schlimm
das wäre mit sicherheit grandios
übertrieben woran liegt das ihrer
meinung nach das ist immer wieder zu
diesen wartezeiten kommt die teilweise
relativ lange wartezeiten sind eine
mischung verschiedener faktoren
ein wichtiger punkt ist der dass
psychotherapeuten sich aussuchen können
mit wem sie arbeiten
es kann also sein dass eine person bei
verschiedenen psychotherapeut auf der
warteliste steht lange wartet werden
gleichzeitig an dieser personen
leichtere fälle die besser zu behandeln
sind vorbei ziehen das ist meines aus
meiner sicht ein ganz wesentlicher
faktor der spitzenverband der
krankenkassen sieht die verantwortung
für die langen wartezeiten also vor
allem bei den psychotherapeuten selbst
dr kirsten kubat konter von den grünen
ist ärztin und psychotherapeutin
sie sitzt im gesundheitsausschuss des
bundestages und kennt die diskussion um
therapieplätze seit jahren
es sind eben interessen von
kostenträgern es sind interessen aus der
ärzteschaft der entscheidende faktor ist
aus meiner sicht dass es die not von
menschen mit seelischen erkrankungen
immer noch unterschätzt wird das auch
die methode psychotherapie in ihrer
wirksamkeit immer noch unterschätzt wird
und möglicherweise auch eine sorge
seitens der kassen dass es hier eine
kostenexplosion geben könnte auch wegen
der pandemie müsse noch mal
nachgebessert werden
wir brauchen eine neue bedarfsplanung
dass wir brauchen wir nicht eine
grundsätzlich neue bedarfserhebung wir
können auf setzen auf das was da ist
zusätzlich müsste addiert werden die
neuen bedürfnisse die durch die
seelischen drucksituationen aus der
pandemie jetzt entstehen und dann müsste
anhand dieser daten die bedarfsplanung
noch mal neu aufgerollt werden
wenn sehen sie denn da politisch am zuge
ist dass der gemeinsame bundesausschuss
oder es auch das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
die entscheidung wird der gemeinsame
bundesausschuss treffen aber die politik
ist natürlich auch gefragt sie darf sich
nicht komplett zurück lehnen und sagen
der gemeinsame bundesausschuss wird
schon regeln sondern politisch können
wir rahmenbedingungen vorgeben
ich bitte das bundesministerium für
gesundheit um ein interview er halte
eine absage
aus zeitlichen gründen schriftlich heißt
es dass das leistungsangebot
international einzigartig sei
das ministerium verweist auf die
zuständigkeit des gemeinsamen
bundesausschusses und die sicherstellung
der versorgung durch die
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen die
probleme in der versorgung psychisch
erkrankter scheinen im ministerium aber
angekommen
das bundesministerium für gesundheit
führt in dieser legislaturperiode einen
dialog zur weiterentwicklung der hilfen
für psychisch erkrankte menschen durch
team ist eine verständigung über
entwicklungsbedarf sowie die
formulierung von empfehlungen
zudem sei der gemeinsame bundesausschuss
bei auf
die versorgung von schweren sowie
strecken
abgeschlossen sein zurück zu sarah weil
sie keinen kassen therapeut fand zahlte
sie 3000 euro für therapiesitzungen von
ihrem ersparten ihre krankenkasse
stimmte nach mehreren monaten einem
antrag auf kostenerstattung zu die
weiteren kosten für die therapie werden
nun übernommen
ich glaube das ist für mich der schritt
der mich zurück in mein normales
selbstbestimmtes leben führt wo ich den
ton angebe und nicht meine angst und wo
ich einfach wieder so sein kann wie ich
vorher war ganz normal arbeiten und ganz
normal mein sozialleben genießen ohne
irgendwelche ängste und einschränkungen
psychische erkrankungen können uns alle
treffen es ist schwer zu verstehen warum
viele betroffene immer noch zu lange auf
einen therapieplatz warten müssen
trotz reformen und veränderungen gerade
in pandemie zeiten sollten wir uns
darauf verlassen können dass es auch bei
psychischen problemen schneller
die
[Musik]